il est venu frappèrent de drogue de
blues hors droits ouais quatre coups des
coteaux pour retrouver à la le thé à la
hauteur c'est très simple c'était à la
hauteur c'est très simple il y en aura
un qui sera allongé ici avec un gobelet
sur le front et y en aura un autre qui
sera là et donc il devra faire couler
d'accord voilà du thé dont le verre on
prendre à quelqu'un téléphone qui
repartira avec une magnifique télé
d'accord c'est donc isabelle vous allez
jouer donc tous les deux qu'ils doivent
verser qui veut j'ai lorsque j'ai un
dîner après pour que ce qui reste à peu
près qu'on va faire le reste
dormez ouais mais est-ce qu'il n'est pas
militant luthier enfin lensois
franchement j'en suis pas sûr à tous les
niveaux david tu vas jouer pour la télé
va devoir choisir qui verse et y reçoit
ils s'en foutent scène alors tu verses
diverses connaissances gilles verdez tu
vas ferment l'excès j'aimerais bien voir
comment il se dépatouille à verser du
tcm trois paires de vote double aux
environs
[Rires]
que par les victimes tirera trop loin
pas mais l'homme du jour sa voix
sensuelle a tonné faire tonner le faire
mais je vois rien la bouche tient le
vert
c'est alors la bouche à valence et
nathan donne à tous les lots
[Applaudissements]
non c'est pas gagné quatremer
dépêche-toi s'est fait tirer sur des
règles
[Applaudissements]
il comptait même percé dans le corner
dans le répertoire est une bouse ils ont
dirigé les becs
alors l'autre je joue pour lui il
m'insulte reagan et face à la serbie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]